you got touched you got power
[Applause]
transformers more than meets the eye
transformers commercial in disguise they
sold a lot of toys with this one wow
she's the kind of a cool set actually
it's almost like I built it by hand or
something I really like it
I feel comfortable how you guys doing
this is my new set for older movie
reviews I decided I wanted to have a
dedicated set for classic movie reviews
since I've had such a great time talking
about so many different films over the
years with you guys I thought it'd be
cool to have a special place just for
that and since transformers the last
night is right around the corner I
thought it'd be a lot of fun to talk
about the original 1986 animated film
that was theatrical the Transformers the
movie and my OCD kind of just wishes it
was called transformers 2 movie but it's
the Transformers dumb movie so it's a
real problem for me so a giant planetary
robot voiced by none other than Orson
Welles named Unicron is destroying
planets and the Decepticons are in the
middle of an all-out war against the
Autobots you can tell this movie is
heavily inspired by anime in fact a lot
of stores put it in the anime section
because it looks quite a bit like every
major Japanese anime that was coming out
of Japan in the 80s any animation is
probably my favorite aspect of this
movie despite the fact that it is fairly
dated there's a lot of times where the
mouth movement of the robot just don't
really mesh up with what the actors are
saying speaking of those actors Leonard
Nimoy voice Galvatron he's pretty cool
in this movie of course the incomparable
Peter Cullen doing Optimus Prime is
probably the best thing your ears can
possibly hear but interestingly Orson
Welles yeah Orson Welles that Orson
Welles voiced Unicron this was his final
film role before his death and it's my
understanding that he wasn't really a
big fan of the movie which I can
understand but at the same time I'm not
really sure what he thought of when he
signed on
to play a giant robot planet I'd say if
you're a huge fan of the Transformers TV
show this movie is going to be amazing I
kind of view it like that x-files movie
actually it bridged the gap between
season five and season six just fine but
if you're kind of walking into it you
might think this is entertaining if you
hadn't seen the TV show you might just
be like oh yeah it looks cool but having
seen the TV show it definitely adds some
weight I'll be honest I haven't seen the
TV show
so watching this movie for the first
time with that shout factory blu-ray I
was just kind of like what I was you
know cool looking and transformer stuff
and at least there weren't any really
annoying human characters it was just
focused on the robots which is great
actually because having seen other
Michael Bay movies I've had my fill of
transformers human characters so it was
nice to see a movie that was basically
just the Transformers actually
themselves but I waited a long time to
see this movie because from what I
understand their release is up until
that shout factory blu-ray weren't very
faithful there's some curse words that
were edited out and censored also pretty
much every release was full frame and
the original theatrical exhibition was
185 so I waited a long time to finally
see this movie and watching the blu-ray
was probably the best experience I could
have had watching it and pretty much
from the opening titles of this movie
that were extremely reminiscent of
Richard Donner's Superman opening titles
I kind of got the vibes of this film was
going for and listening to the score
especially you cannot escape that this
is a 1980s movie and it's not really a
surprise to me to the composer of this
movie is the same composer of rocky 4
because these soundtracks are almost
interchangeable
[Music]
and it's mostly just a fun enough action
movie that you can watch from beginning
to end but it does have some really
strange tones that sometimes compete
with each other like for instance
there's this scene where this guy
chronics is in jail and there's this
kangaroo court that's being run by
people who throw people who are innocent
or guilty but mostly innocent into a
pool filled with sharkticons now these
sharkticons eat people up and then
everyone the court laughs and they've
had a great day
this guy cranek is innocent and the
judge is like you're innocent and then
they throw him in this pool and it gets
destroyed by the sharkticons now that's
kind of dark it's more dark than you
would expect for a movie like this and
somebody even says in this movie I
was like woah it's okay I didn't expect
that but then there's a scene like where
all the Transformers meet some people on
another planet and they just kind of
form a circle and start dancing and that
heap is just hilariously out of place I
kind of loved it though and I laughed
quite a bit during it so in that way I'm
actually fine with it but it just
doesn't really make sense it's like wait
someone's got devoured who didn't do
anything and now they're all dancing in
a circle it was kind of like Return of
the Jedi where like the Ewoks are so
cute and everything and then all of a
sudden the Emperor's electrocuting Luke
and you're like oh it's just this
weird mishmash of tone sometimes but for
the most part the Transformers movie is
basically made to sell some toys and to
keep people interested in the animated
TV show and in that way it's perfectly
enjoyable I would say if you have
nostalgia for this movie you're
obviously going to like it a lot more
than I did because I had never seen it
until now and watching it for the first
time now I definitely enjoyed it
somewhat more than Michael Bay's
transformers movie because as I said
there's no annoying children in this
well there's one kid but he's not really
movie that that much but my eyes and my
brain can be critical sometimes I can't
help but turn it off so there's a scene
in the movie where the Autobots are
underwater and they're like fighting
these these monsters and they're fine
they don't need oxygen but later in the
movie Galvatron is like choking out one
of them are like why are you choking him
like he doesn't need oxygen
what is choking a robot going to do
exactly
what a plot hole a massive horrible plot
hole continuity error that no one cares
about so like I said this movie is
perfectly enjoyable if you view it as a
gap between season 2 and season 3 of the
show if you just kind of watch it
through and feel like you're already
with these characters and you feel some
investment there you're going to have
fun with it on that level but if you're
just watching this as an adult for the
first time you've never really watched
the show like me you're probably going
to feel a little polarized by it and
wonder what all the hype is about but
it's still perfectly enjoyable and the
animation even though it is heavily
inspired by anime and it does feel kind
of blatant that it's like obviously
totally anime inspired it's enjoyable
enough to watch we even have a good time
of it I'm gonna give the Transformers
the movie of the - so guys I hope you
like my new set this is going to be
where I sum all of my classic movie
reviews from now on whenever I do a
review of an older film it's going to be
here I also built a new set for
hilarious ities right over there that
I'll start using whenever I do hilarious
ities from now on
of course my new release reviews and
anime and games and stuff like that will
be back at my older set and I like the
idea of having an interchangeable set it
helps differentiate the the videos and
it's just fun I enjoy building things
like this is a lot of fun to build so
guys thank you so much as always for
watching look forward to my reviews of
transformers transformers revenge of the
Fallen and Transformers Dark of the Moon
I'm going to enjoy doing it and I'm
going to enjoy doing a few guys you guys
are the best thank you very much for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]